progressives basically you know they
came out there was a generational thing
they were the youngsters the 60s they're
fighting against their parents um and it
was an ideology that sort of came out of
rebellion and it's always defined Itself
by you know by being like you know
against the man and then once you you
are the man like what do you do then
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is a
writer for unheard and an author Ed West
Welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me it's so great to have you on
um we've been really enjoying many of
the Articles you wrote and your latest
books more men on the wrong side of
History which is about the decline and
potential unlikely return of
conservatism as you put it and we'll get
into that of course
um but before we get into the
conversation itself let me ask you a
very broad question which is mainly who
are you how are you where you are what
has been your journey through life
um well as I sort of put in the book the
book is basically a bit of orthography
as well um I'm one of those lame people
who's never went on that sort of Journey
from left to right which I sort of
I always feel jealous of those people
because
um I suppose I was basically always
quite conservative and uh
but as I got older I sort of noticed
that my friends were actually becoming
like more liberal as the whole you know
the whole world basically went in the
direction so that was the major book um
I mean from London my parents are both
journalists so it was kind of inevitable
that I'd get into this my dad was a
foreign correspondent during the Cold
War and he started off
as a communist and he became very
reactionally like comically reactiony
um Peter Hitchens did he oh yeah I think
it went beyond beautician yeah he was
like ancient Enlightenment he thought
was a terrible idea you know he's you
know he was basically probably made evil
really
um
yeah it's a little bit eccentric so
that's why I think that you know
basically influenced me so I was
basically born with the red pill you
know my mouth it was just it was never
any of that useful frolicking with
liberalism
um so yeah so that was very much like
the cold war sort of background
atmosphere so we sort of knew all about
that
um you know as communism was kind of
this great evil
um
and now I've grown up and the Communists
are sort of winning I think in a way in
a kind of strange way well
psychologically yeah we'll get into that
because one of the most fascinating
articles I've read in recent times was
your piece about how actually the
cultural revolution is complete right
and maybe let's get right into that tell
when you say the Communists are kind of
winning what do you mean it sounds a bit
Reds under the bed to a lot of people
yeah it probably might make me sound
like a bit of a loony but that's
probably true
um but basic things I noticed about you
know the kind of people in the past you
did like personality traits match
politics so if you're quotes
um if you're quite conscientious and
uptights and you know really obsessed
like I was really early today because
I'm a conservative I hate being late
um so conscientious people tend to be
like quite conservative well people are
more neurotic and more open-minded tend
to be liberal so that's why the Arts are
liberal but what I noticed more and more
recently is that if you meet someone
who's very conscientious and uptight the
kind of person in the 50s would be like
you know your arch conservative they now
The Young Ones anyway tend to sort of
believe in all the sort of progressive
sort of ideas the dominant ideas you
know they will you know they will be
obviously very Pro remain
um they will be they'll be quite
synthetic to BLM because it's like a
decent thing to do you know quality
um and so gas Southgate was basically
like a sort of
stopping off point of that article you
know he said that we should take the
knee and I thought well that's kind of
interesting but now
that's what happens when a revolution is
done
you know the actual revolution has
become quite conservative because now
they're fixed in place they control
things I mean it's the same with the
Communist regimes Eastern Europe were
like very conservative they're full of
old men they hate to change they were
now fixed in place
um and so you know they had their own
sort of moral order and they didn't want
it changed and I think that's what's
kind of happened you know the the period
we grow up and I mean especially comedy
like the Golden Age of Comedy was
probably around the turn of the
Millennium in my view because
um
everything was kind of up for grabs
everything was a question like Seinfeld
was all about because no one knows what
the what is like the social Norm about
stuff there's less confusion
um now that so much comedy which
couldn't be made in 2000 I mean which
was mainly like that period which
couldn't have been made in the 60s now
can't be made again I used the example
of Life of Brian which could never be
made now uh just as it could never be
made in 1960. I mean the joke about
you know a man who calls himself a woman
which would obviously being so
self-evidently stupid in that time you
just that would be possible to make now
um You couldn't blaspheme Jesus because
he's a prophet of Islam uh you know I
mean there is basically it's a fact
though blasphemy law about Islam is that
people don't want to be beheaded
generally um it's not a good career move
it's definitely not a good green
generally I mean loads of people come up
they say oh you know well I think I want
to punch down I don't want to you know
because our minds is like I want my head
on my body that's like a base it's about
fear yeah right yeah
um but then you know the trans thing is
also
you know that's also enforcing for you
and that's a sort of new like Pride like
all the teenagers like love pride and
pride is basically the same as like 100
years ago or 50 years ago if you went to
Malta or Ireland or Poland and the
Corpus Christi procession were in June
all the kids dress up and you know
uh show their faith in the sort of State
religion and now pride is basically that
I mean that so to summarize the argument
what you're really saying is we had a
cultural revolution yeah where a lot of
these Progressive ideas were Advanced
and embedded into society and now we're
at the point where it's the sort of
middle management rung of society the
people who who used to be the face of
conservatism
Etc this has become the new conservative
tradition in a way this says even I mean
it's based on some very like
unconservative ideas fundamentally
progressivism is unconservative because
it's
you know it's based on the blank slate
it's all these kind of ideas but I mean
you know the Scotts Alexander I don't
even follow he's he writes his blog in
California it's just great it's the best
blog and he makes the example you know
he talks about the kind of like maiden
aunts in the 50s who disapproved of
everyone and you know the one the kind
of classic they know young men really
like because they've all stopped from
having fun you know so tell you off your
language tell your about who what you're
saying you're reading the wrong books
those if you heard about someone who has
stopped me reading books now or telling
you about language you could guarantee
100 to be on the left it will be I mean
it's almost scary you know that same
person is now saying you can't read that
book because that can't have that book
because it's racist rather than you know
because it was sexual or
um you know I don't want these bad
people who have the wrong ideas of I
mean there are just you know there are
so many different examples of that where
there is you know ideas are now fixed
and there are sort of moral codes you
know like we had the C words and now
it's the n words I mean
I think in the same you know every
society needs these kind of taboos and
needs these you know things that can't
be said
um but you know it's I don't know and
also the other thing is the moral
relativism that was a massive thing you
know that was a classic sort of like
Daily Mail things all these moral
relativists like when was the last time
you heard that talked about the left
being moral relativists then they're not
I mean they are completely the most I
mean as left broadly I mean sort of the
activists on campus the sort of
progressives you know the work people
they're not moral relatives they're
absolutely
um confirmed in their moral beliefs you
know there's there's no doubts about it
whatsoever so that's what happens when
you take control you don't
allow these kind of questions of of
Doubt anymore and what effect does that
have on society that we're not allowed
to question that we're not allowed to
play with these kind of ideas
I mean I I don't I think you can never
have effective outcomes if you have
taboos about what is what is true I mean
I think the Afghanistan things classic
example are you I mean how the U.S has
spent is it a trillion and it's going to
be it's gonna be two trillion when you
know deal with all the broken lives back
in America
this is all based on a completely
fraudulent idea of what what is possible
with afghanistanity you know it's
completely naive idea we can turn
Afghanistan into liberal State it's a
very you know tribal culture even taking
away the religious actually because
there are Muslim countries which can be
liberal but Afghanistan is a incredibly
clannished Society it was just never
gonna happen if you could openly say
listen the Afghans are not going to be
liberal Democrats
um there's huge amounts of taboos about
stuff like that so instead that kind of
really wasn't discussed properly the
result was thousands of deaths 20 years
of wasted lives you know two trillion
dollars you know you should have
absolutely
I don't believe there should be no
taboos but you should be able to sort of
say really uncomfortable truths the
truth should not be taboo is what you're
really saying yeah I mean and there are
loads of areas where
you know we can never really say
honestly what we think truth is because
don't want their lives are indeed I mean
no one really wants to be a heretic do
they Aurora I mean they're Crush people
don't put them in gulags anymore but no
one wants to be unemployable or you know
even worse have your you know bank card
removed you know in the worst cases I
mean let's push back on that a little
bit there are people who have made
careers that are being canceled that is
one of the arguments and gained a
certain notoriety for themselves so is
that really true I think there is you
know there are certain people who enjoy
that kind of thing I'm certainly you
have to be really disagreeable kind of
person
um you know it's like Katie Hopkins or
someone who likes being this kind of
handsome man villain likes being hated
um and then you can make a certainly but
even they get you know the career move
is very short even like something like
Milo yianopolis you know eventually he
was taken on Twitter and it's like oh
we're making stronger and more notorious
no it just ended his career now he's on
some like no Mark social website
um but very few people I mean and those
are sort of professional you know a
professional economists can say these
things to a certain extent and be hated
and they'll sell a lot of job but it's
the people in sort of ordinary jobs so
you can't say it I mean loads and loads
of people have been sacked for example
even after the BLM thing you know loads
of people saying oh you know can I just
points out George Floyd wasn't like
exactly a saint you know you might have
actually done something you know been to
prison and blah blah and you know like
eight there are eight or nine people who
are sacked after that in Britain
um in various small jobs you know
there's a policeman who sent that
a George Floyd joke on his you know he
was actually you know he's actually
prosecuted by the police that's that
joke it's literally a blasphemy law it's
um
I mean that it's I mean that is you know
a real issue I think that
people do feel like slightly scared so
voice minions they do feel that I I
completely agree they do feel scared to
voice opinions how have we let it go
this far though because surely EV the
vast majority of people in this country
what don't agree with that they don't
agree with that with where We've Ended
up I don't know I mean how many people
in the Taliban they're quite small
aren't they they managed to
but take over the country I mean I think
a very small number of people are quite
determined can really I mean what is the
latest polls I mean like eight percent
of Americans would identify themselves
as work or something
um and you know those eight percent
happen to be disproportionately educated
you know well off
influential and also like very
determined they're very small
minority can really change the country
rapidly change the culture
um and you know you'll have that eight
percent but you'll have another 20 you
probably think well you know I'm not
really them for them but I I dislike the
right more so give them the you know one
of the examples I use in the book is you
know the Reformation
but it's you know the Reformation
started there were tiny little minority
in University not University well in
Cambridge and London who are sort of you
know radical Protestants and they you
know they were timers and then 50 years
later they were the majority and then
you know the Catholics all of a sudden
was you know the wrong side of History
essentially you mentioned the
Reformation because the Reformation of
course I mean arguably was caused by
technological progress right the
printing press essentially allowed
people to be possible without it yeah
and it's kind of similar to where we are
now the parallel is there exactly I mean
not to the internet starts it
um and then social media kind of
accelerates it I mean the great
awokening there have been like such a
rapid change in
um public opinion amongst Democrats in
America particularly upper middle class
in just eight years which is just so
unprecedented that amount of shift
um and that is entirely social media-led
I think you know it's just
it can spread ideas
so quickly
to the point where I think Barack Obama
running in 2012 or talking in 2014 can
talk about the southern Border in
exactly the same way that Donald Trump
talked about it but in in a period of
six or eight years we've gone from that
position being the standard position
shared across both parties right to
where now anyone who says what Barack
Obama said only a few years ago is now
you're just racist now you can I mean
you can Trump's tone is obviously
what his actual policies and you track
them and you know what what Clinton was
saying about and Clinton's you know
immigration advisor you know he was a
black woman in the mid 90s what they're
saying about diversity immigration will
just put you so beyond the pale and that
was just completely normal
um
I know people I say of course society's
change but it's changed so quickly in
such rapid space is
I think like generally disturbing I mean
I I mean at what point
you know I know people disagree about oh
the you know younger people are going to
Rebel about it I mean I've always been a
bit pessimistic about that although
recently
I've kind of slightly changed my mind I
think maybe there will be a little bit
but I don't know I mean when people say
oh you know like the transgender
movement another issue where people you
know generally scared say that it comes
more and more extreme
um positions become normalized and I
always think at what point you know
when's the sort of you know the retreat
when's the fight back gonna come and it
just never does it just gets more and
more bizarre until
something that was completely normal
four years ago and I was considered like
you know hate speech literally
um and what would you say to those
people go look mate hang on a second
here we've got a conservative government
in charge the reality is uh with the way
labor is we're never going to get a
leftist government for certainly for the
next few years you know let's say 10
years yeah no no I agree with that yeah
yeah so you know what what are you
complaining about
um I mean the conservative party is very
good at you know at maintaining power
um by by basically you know except the
amount of chain that's fine and you know
being a more moderate version but you
know I would argue conservatives have
limited political power in this country
I mean it's limited by the fact that you
have to get elected and you know the
Scotland majority but the left has like
absolute cultural power you know like
almost there is almost zero
um opposition to leftist coach power so
how many is the Deep state but all the
institutions that when the country are
basically leftists and there's very
little
seemed very like little conservative
episodes like to actually fight that
would be a really really like costly
effort when you say fight you so when
you talk about the institutions what the
BBC I'm guessing I mean not just the BBC
but I mean like Charities for example
um you know
if you meet people working at home
office you're you know there's people
say oh I don't believe in prison it's
the sort of you know it's barbaric in
100 years time we'll have no prison site
you your job is to put people in prison
like how can you or Minister of Justice
so
um
you know the people within that are not
conservatives and I mean even even with
this thing in Stonewall like Stonewall
you know the government says oh we're
gonna have some fight back we're gonna
stop Stone will cooperate with stone
will um over the trans things like what
on Earth will Stonewall doing in schools
in the first place you're you've been in
power for 10 years that is a very you
know Progressive organization that is
not something you should be sporting and
they only fight back on on you know the
trans issue was was fire basically
feminists who are the people who sort of
got the balls so to speak to stand up to
more extreme elements so that you can't
even you know conserve this can't even
fight that issue they have to sort of
get leftist allies to do the fighting
for them so there's you know very this
is why I mean this is one of the reasons
why I'm not you know so mad about brexit
is that I think they've just put all
their kind of
all their effort was going into brexit
basically like we got to win this one
argument and you know what little energy
we've got is going to go in this and you
know we're not gonna bother with any
other sort of basic fight we have to
have
Ed I think we've come and I to a point
and I'm sure that you would agree with
this where the labels we traditionally
use Left Right conservative liberal
they've kind of lost their meaning
right because 20 years ago you could
argue that everybody's sitting in this
room is a liberal
gay marriage you know all of these
things which you would ascribe to being
liberal right yeah okay now we fast
forward whatever it is 20 years I don't
think anybody in this room would be
described as liberal I'm liberal well I
mean you but you see you're using your
American language yeah yeah yeah you
know we've lost that battle I mean
liberal I believe in Freedom I believe
in maximizing people's freedom why when
did that stop being liberal it just did
I mean I would definitely say what you I
mean what the what Americans though is
liberal is very is is no way liberalism
right yeah it's a real shame that you
know both opponents insist on you know
calling them liberals still they just
refuse to do it Sprint store you know
the the ideology which I suppose began
really had its roots in the 60s that I
call it progressivism because I don't
know I think that's what they I think
it's fair to yeah they would they would
be fair with that it's not an insultism
um it believes in certain core issues
but you know it doesn't it's not it's
not pro-free speech necessarily by
Progressive stencil it's not it's not
for a pro um freedom of Association
which is by almost by definition racist
and sexist
um you know it doesn't believe in
those kind of core like beliefs that
John Locke came up and said in that way
liberal conservatism is still I mean I
know left and right
I mean I think there is still a sort of
basic psychological mindset that differs
between left and right there is still a
that was always tracked
I guess what what you're getting now
though is Peter Hitchens for example
would say the conservatives are no
longer conservative either right exactly
yeah I mean he's been saying that for
quite a long time
I mean I love hitches it's great yeah
that's labels don't really mean what
they used to me what's my point right
I think that's partly because
progressives are in power and someone's
who are in power you're like you're your
mindset changes I mean my problem is
like progressives basically you know
they came out there was a generational
thing there were the youngsters of the
60s are fighting against their parents
um and it was an ideology that sort of
came out of rebellion and it's always
defined Itself by you know by being like
you know against the man and then once
you you are the man like what do you do
then I mean like how you then frame it
you know you just end up fighting these
complete like straw man battles against
like an establishment which is just
completely gone you know all this thing
about oh you know why why aren't we
being taught like about the
you know the British event this is all
the stuff you're not taught at school
about the British numbers like when was
the last time like tissue tissues were
like really right wing it's like when I
was down in the 80s they all you know
they were they weren't like members of
the Empire loyalists at the time that
like teachers have been Lefty for like
50 or 60 years like who who you arguing
against you're arguing against something
that stopped being true
they're making other kids are like
learning our Island story at school but
all they're fighting against is like
a society never really exists anymore um
it's interesting that you said because I
think that's so true in comedy that a
lot of comedians certainly not in our
experience or my experience felt like
they were pushing against the system
right when it was quite clearly
observable by the decisions that were
being made who was being booked to do TV
Etc that that way of thinking is
embedded as the system exactly I mean
like you're not it's not so you're not
fighting back against the man you're not
fighting back against anything you are
part of the system that's propagating
itself I mean that does make you know
good comedy so like you know Dave Allen
when he made jokes about the Catholic
church I mean that's the classic example
I use people were really scared of the
church in Ireland you know like that can
make your life a misery um so when he
was sort of making these kind of jokes
it'd be real that'd be really funny
because people would be thinking that
you know I've been thinking I've been
thinking that my whole life and I can't
say it
um but yeah I mean if you're making
jokes about a sort of conservative
system now there's just you know people
where is it everyone says yeah usually
you know there's the pride flag flying
from all our government buildings like
where's
where's the humor there so the second
part of my question right Ed yeah no
good you apologize
but not I love watching English people
yeah this
um what does it mean what is
conservatism now what does it mean to be
a conservative
well that's a good question I mean I
didn't actually finish answering the
first one was like the conservative
party has always been an alliance
between conservatives and liberals I
mean that has been for well not always
it's been for about since the labor
party arose so you know you have
different factions within it which you
know Liz trust is a liberal and that's
fine because it's basically the
conservative party was like an
anti-socialist alliance so its main job
was to stop the basically like labor
ruining economy
you know so but at the time labor you
know between labor and conservative
there wouldn't have been like until the
60s there was no kind of cultural
differences they all would have been you
know it all would have been by today's
standards completely Beyond The Pale
um and it only say in the 60s and labor
starts becoming more liberal so
yeah you're right I mean
there are some like conservative MPS who
are like you know full-on conservative I
mean what does it mean the Jacob Reese
marks of the world
Jacob yeah he's yeah he's a uh I suppose
he's a proper conservative isn't he
I mean it's like one anyway I mean yeah
he looks like I mean I I never know if
he's is he laughing or not is this all
like a bit of a Persona I don't know I
don't know so
um but the point you're making is is a
fair one he's a parody of a conservative
I think that's the only way you can
actually get away that now is by
becoming a bit like a bit of a joke or
like you can't do it earnestly because
then you're just a Monster yeah exactly
then you'll just be like you're
the conservative classic arguments say
oh I'm just there to put the brakes on
though you know driving the speed limit
or
um
sort of stop things accelerating the
problem is like when things accelerate
so much if your job is just to slow
things down it's like what are we
heading towards like
I mean take with the Trans issue or like
with diversity like
at one point you just say like no it's
not enough there's no one I mean it
seems very hard for someone to
articulate that
without kind of being monsters and I
think there isn't really
there isn't much kind of like no one's
really volunteering to be that kind of
the bad guy it's it's um
I mean basically since about the 1990s
conservatives like opinions have been
publicly quite taboo like saying you
know probably conservative stuff now
what are we talking about well I think
if you look back at um say the
immigration thing in the late 90s you
know Blair massively increased
immigration um
I did the report ages go on the abbc for
this
and in some you know in some cases
they'll have like five or six people
lining up saying this is great amazing
and then you have one
um you know bad story it's basically his
job was like the guy in wrestling
dressed up like Iranian yeah you must
have like you know body music and
there's all presenters like you know how
can you you know possibly object to a
Multicultural Society you know you're
basically a monster you know power
you're you know you're beyond the pale
and you know this is a
conservative view was supported by the
majority of people yeah
um still is it arguably yeah although
that's kind of losing because you know
just reality you know I think with like
diversities once you have diversity it's
you know to boots it's irreversible
because it will it'll be so monstrous to
reverse it
um secondly said enough and then
like where does it stop I mean all these
processes with progressivism there's no
end point that's the thing you know it's
kind of just sign surrender papers and
say okay it's over now can we just move
on to the next you know can we just get
on with our lives okay
um
there has to be I mean that's even the
gay marriage so gay marriage is a good
thing it's it's you know it's definitely
defensible and conservative grounds
I wonder would you have to gay marriage
and and just end it there will it get
marriage inevitably lead to like the
trans stuff becoming really like extreme
I don't know I mean is it possible to
end any of these changes at one point
and say that's good I don't want any
more dude I'm not sure it is really do
you buy into the argument that a lot of
these institutions like Stonewall did
great work in the 1960s well let's be
let's be honest go people faced real
oppression I mean Stone Wilson later
they're named after
um 60 70s and all the rest of it but
they had their roots in the 60s itself
yeah well they're named after this they
were all right yeah I mean there's
there's no doubt about it
um you know every Revolution like has
good points right I mean the French
Revolution uh
was you know very necessary the system
has a change you know I would argue that
like beheading thousands of people might
have been a bit of an excess
um that's a very English way of putting
it in I mean
a Soviet functionary whose job it was to
kill off all the people in the purchase
Center when you chop wood uh Little Bits
will fly
I mean I'm reading a book about the
Russian Revolution I mean I'd say
there's probably not much that came out
of that but you know the system was
rotten to start with yeah there's loads
that need you know changing in society
in the 60s
um you know I wouldn't argue about that
I just think Revolution revolutions have
in themselves a sort of uh
no real endpoint so it's you know it's
inevitably
just going to go more and more sort of
crazy what about the idea that I think a
lot of people are hopeful and look as
you say you you were a conservative from
from birth I I I'm not conservative I
think temperamentally I don't know about
Francis I think you're becoming
conservative aren't you mate I'm going
to be on it yeah I think I am yeah there
we go he's still pretending well I mean
I say as you get older you just can't
help it no but the thing is the thing is
the the what's happened is Francis was
always on the old school left it's just
the old school left us now yeah right
and that is definitely true there's
uh but but a lot of people like me who
who are simultaneously not conservative
but also deeply deeply against this
Progressive ideology the hope I have is
as you you alluded to earlier that young
people rebel against the the their their
parents generation essentially and now
the children that are being born now are
from basically this point forward going
to be born to Millennials and younger
people right so that if there are any
children I mean which is another issue
with a touche
but but those that are those that are
being born they are going to be they're
going to be looking at their parents
being useless and talking about adulting
and looking at that going actually and
then you know we need to go full Trad
don't you think that's gonna happen I
think maybe I mean if you if you've got
a liberal mindset you don't like
sanctimonious people telling you off
saying you can't do that and then
inevitably those people now that's my
issue with this whole ideology I mean as
a kids I you know I when I went to
church I really didn't like the sort of
the sanctimonious old people who sort of
say look I'm better than you are look
how much you know it's very like
invisible Irish Catholic church and just
so the whole point is to look it's more
miserable and I'm better than you
because I'm more miserable you're
smiling like you can't do that
um and those and that's what I sort of I
saw a lot of that amongst lefties that
kind of you know I'm that hadn't yet I'm
taking this more seriously the
environment's more importantly I say
racism all that kind of thing
um so I kind of get that and so if you
are of that mindset
um then yeah you probably will be a bit
more a bit more opposed to I mean I
think with the
like the trans thing is really
interesting because the trans thing I
mean the argument that like a lot of
feminists say which I think is true is
that it's like a very cons I mean it's
not it's radical interpretation sex but
it's also really conservative you know
it's like if you're a girly boy then you
must be really a girl or if you're a
very masculine or gender atypical girl
you must be really big boy
you know and seeing the people in the
60s would say no you're just gender
atypical you know you're probably
lesbian or gay and that's fine you can
just do but yeah now you sort of have to
have these kind of strict things and
also this kind of obsession with
categorization
and identity which is like a very
conservative thing you know like the
conservative mindset and needs
categories because that's how they sort
of see the world that's how they order
it
um so that is a very sort of
conservative thing so if you don't like
categorization if you don't like the
sort of forced kind of almost like
semi-religious like order of Pride which
is very like you must do this because
this is what the community does
then yeah you might turn against this I
mean I think I don't think young people
will be conservative I think they'd
probably be anti-work which is like more
what you are like a liberal anti-work
person
which there are a lot of people you know
lots of people honestly will honestly
say you know like I'm liberal but
there's only one group of people who are
basically like threatening my ability to
sort of you know talk normally
do this is what a lot of academics say
so secretly
um about you know liberal academics you
say you know the only people who
bothering me who like make life
difficult are the kind of like
Progressive
um sort of ideologues you sort of run
the place but no no conservatives saying
you can't study that or you have to do
this or something you know if they were
they you know if they were in power they
probably would but you know they're not
so so that's what I'm asking you do you
think there will be a flip where that
changes because I always laugh when
people accuse me of being on the right
because I'm like I almost I have almost
no doubt that 15 years from now I will
be fighting against
the right wing socially conservative uh
religious right as as comedians like
Bill Hicks and George Carlin were in the
90s I have no doubt that there will be a
point in my life with those are the
people that are very optimistic to me
yeah that'd be great I think that is
optimistic but you think that's not
going to happen I think I mean I mean I
think there might be a religious right
in Britain that is powerful but I don't
think it will be a Christian one
um
can I say that yes come on let's explore
that
um I I know I didn't think there's gonna
be I think once a religion goes into
decline I think there's always nothing
that can be done to stop it to be honest
um
and I don't think there's going to be a
religious movement there's not and I
think without religion you don't really
get social conservatism because
the kind of default like mindset then
becomes utilitarianism I mean if you're
not religious then utilitarianism just
makes so much sense
that it's impossible to argue against
really like um why is that
I just think it's
I wouldn't say it's necessarily the best
argument but like if you're trying to
order a society how else are you gonna
do it I mean if you're safe like you
know the gay marriage thing if you're a
kind of traditionalist capturing you say
well marriage is a Sacrament it says it
has to be the same amount of women
review to let her and say well
marriage is about
um you know people loving each other
wants to make a partnership there's no
utilitarian argument against it
um doesn't harm you so why you know why
not there's there are so many different
examples of um
I'm trying to think about the move
towards the utilitarianism is basically
just inevitable if you're not religious
so I just don't think you can have a
sort of socially conservative movement
without religion
uh yeah I I agree with you and then I
don't know you're not going to be facing
some sort of like you know Council or
Vatican index sensors in 15 years I
reckon it would just be like the same
white people but even worse
well there you go guys that's that's
reassuring that and even crazy a lot you
you but I mean we've always seen this
throughout history the Ebbs and flows
and it's never linear in that way yeah
you just think do you do you think
there's never going to be a pushback
against this it's just it's gonna be the
new Dogma forever and we're just going
to get more and more Progressive I don't
know I I think it's impossible to
predict the future isn't it I mean
people tend to predict what they want to
believe I would love to think that you
know the Next Generation I mean the only
thing I you know I did lose this book is
that there is huge birth gap between
conservatives and liberals and it's
really opened up and never used to be
so you know liberal societies produce
more conservative people I mean in the
50s I think in America you know the
average liberal it was like three or
four kids each and now it's like 2.2
Kids versus one and the difference is
you know if you're a liberal person 60s
you're probably still be basically
pressured into getting married
um by social forces well now there's
more freedom everyone can basically
choose their own little niche uh I think
that'll take a long time to have an
impact
um
you know we're talking about generations
and it's hard to say I mean there are so
many factors out there aren't they I
mean like what is the Chinese influence
on Western Society going to be I mean is
that
I mean I'm pretty pessimistic to be
honest I just think it'll be like
unbelievably horrible but um
that will definitely affect how you know
the left and rights see each other that
populate
that is a very good point because that
is a conflict that we're not talking
about and that we seem to have buried
our heads in the sand about because when
you think about a lot of our huge you
know multinational companies they're in
Hook to China yeah yeah uh you know
Money Talks isn't it I mean the thing
the Soviet Union was undeniably like a
force of evil but it was also
economically
inettes so it was never going to really
I mean once once in the 70s you know
Hungary and all these other countries
were so in hot to the West for money so
once you're you know once you open your
money they basically control you
you know but try I mean and you go back
to the other sort of tyrannies we faced
um you know Nazism was utterly evil but
and it you know but it was inevitably
going to lead to war very quickly and we
had to destroy it
Chinese communism Chinese whatever it is
I mean they that is in a way more
dangerous because they are
we basically owe them you know huge
amounts of money and you know what's
going to be
what's going to be you know done in
exchange for that
so yeah that's that's another thing too
pessimistic about isn't it I've got a
few more
a few more black pills I started off as
a kid with the red pills now he's
dropping yeah do you think Trump was
right when he
highlighted the threat of China
uh I mean that that's kind of
universally accepted amongst Americans
isn't it that's the only thing they
agree on Democrats and Republicans uh I
mean I think in retrospect I mean it's
great that you know there is a Stephen
Pinker size to me that you know it's
great that poverty is declined you know
like everywhere every day like a million
people come out of poverty but a huge
amount of that was through China's entry
into the World trades organization 2001.
um
which is probably like uh I didn't you
know it wasn't as big as 9 11 obviously
as an issue but it did basically ship
two million you know American
manufacturing jobs you know it triggers
the basic the Great Awakening the shift
American society was basically down to
this change uh and then same time
completely empowered China made you know
chimerica is a is definitely a thing and
I didn't you know they're not fools the
people who run the Chinese Communist
party no they they will want something
back from there and you know slowly
slowly and surely as British
institutions are brought up by the
Chinese and you know British public
schools which universities British
corporations eventually the thing is you
know that guy is criticizing China and
social media so get rid of him that
would become a normal thing and then I
think
I think the kind of progressive taboos
have almost made us more open to
cowardness as well this is what I'm
slightly worried about it's like if that
becomes the norm so you know well
you know I can't say something about
like
you know George Floyd or the transition
movement you know maybe I should just be
cute quiet about
the Chinese Communist party you know
because that's at least they've got
loads of money so
um you know already there are lots of
media people will be brought up with
them I mean that's what the money is
isn't it so well we've definitely got an
oversupply of journalists who need money
so that'll be like very easy to get
speaking of Journalism I mean that's in
there obviously you're involved with
directly yourself but uh I've been
watching and commenting on the decline
of the media right for quite some time
we just had Glenn Greenwald on to talk
about it right what what do you think
has happened to the media because
there's quite a lot of evidence that the
great awokening is actually something
that was led large by Elite discourse
New York Times right the most evil
newspaper in the world but I mean
without doubt and I you know I don't
even say ironically
um yeah in their use of
you know core kind of moralizing words
it's just massively increased you can
you know those charts have been done by
various academics
um yeah I mean that is it is a creation
of a few journalists I mean the main
thing is obviously the internet has
emptied it so
it's just much cheaper to run these kind
of you know cultural
sort of Articles than like a proper
investigation or a news story that is
really expensive journalism there's just
not the money here for it so it's much
easier to make these kind of commentary
things our chairs racist yeah yeah
exactly yeah I mean but it's got so much
worse I mean there's another day saying
racial slur at baseball game or
something and it was like Paige and then
you got to that paragraph 36 said oh
yeah and it probably wasn't the n-word
it's something else what the point was
his entire article about someone says
rude words hold the front page
um yeah they've definitely got worse and
there is ever you know there's
definitely there are statistics on
American journalists their political
slant as um
you know hugely changed I mean they've
always been more left sensored because
writers tend to be more left of
sensitive but by by about by the time
that Barack Obama
I got elected it was like overwhelmingly
left Center and you know and public you
know public opinion is often
not accurate but they have a rough idea
what's going on so trust in the media is
hugely increasing and I think there's a
decrease decrease sorry the other one um
I think it was like you know it was like
nine now ten Americans thought you know
the the media was basically trying to
get Barack Obama elected of course they
were they were openly biased about the
whole thing the only thing about Trump
is because Trump is like such like a
comically bad guy you know like a really
funny and evil person who says terrible
things he has this he had this amazing
ability to just basically draw out their
extremism you'll say something stupid
their reaction was just like you just
revealed how mad you are as well like
you're you know the thought leaders are
the greatest country in the world and
you're utterly off your rocket all of
you you know so some of them many of
these people are just so much more
extreme than the rest of the population
like how did you end up in positions of
power it's amazing but ironically they
need Trump because the moment yeah all
the ratings and their you know went
through the floor I know that they had a
sort of dynamic didn't they together the
media interrupt I mean that I think
their source of turning against spider
now aren't they looks like someone yeah
someone I think someone tweeted out they
actually like did the transcript of what
you're saying I mean he's clearly
not mentally at his best
and it was just I'm I'm only just he's
obviously yeah so you know they would
never do that before especially in the
run-up to election where they sort of
made it clear that you know their job
was to get Biden elected
do you want to promote your business to
an intelligent audience who don't need
to know your pronouns to buy your
product here at trigonometry we have
over 250
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and we frequently get over 3
million views a month that's a lot of
new customers for your business we speak
with some of the biggest guests from the
worlds of politics economics journalism
arts and entertainment all of them has
spent at least one month in the gulag so
you don't have to and will match your
product to the perfect guest for you
American sponsors will be match with
American guests and so on that way you
know your advert has the best possible
chance of getting to the right people or
as we call them the wrong people
advertise with us and we'll get your
business canceled or your money back
contact us by email at marketing
triggerpod dot Co dot UK and we'll make
your nightmares come true
what happened to the idea of the media
holding the powerful to account wasn't
that the purpose of the media
um I I don't know I think yeah yeah
obviously I mean
I mean yeah isn't in some ways but I
think when you know America is so
polarized isn't it though
it's people's polarization hits a
certain point people don't really think
about that all matters is like winning
all the matters is
you know stopping the other side from
scoring a point because it becomes so
existential isn't it stop
I mean I cannot understand like Trump
was like it was kind of unnerving you
know seeing this is like man in charge
of America and you tweet it's completely
Reckless stuff so I can see why you know
it was such an exact you know important
point to get rid of him
um but yeah I think that once that
happens you know there aren't that many
people who would you know take a massive
hit for their team if it was if it was
in the interest of democracy other I
don't think we're we're as bad I mean I
didn't
I think we could get slightly back but
we could get worse but I didn't think
we'll ever be
I don't think we can be as bad as
America just the dynamic of such a huge
country so sort of diverse and not just
culturally but like socially as well
what would you say to those people go
look actually right the old institutions
are crumbling but this is a good thing
this is important this is necessary
they're no longer fit for purpose look
unheard and heard it's developed you
know a huge fan base Colette we've got
sub stack now where people can go and
access the journalists that they like
and trust and pay for them and subsidize
them isn't that a positive
um
there are some I mean the substance is a
great idea in their sense that you know
journalists can make more money which is
that a good journalist can make more
money and you know I think Market
Dynamic you know Market does reveal sort
of a central truth about a lot of stuff
that you know if no one's going to pay
for your writing then
I think it is important to have like
stuff like in you know investigative
reporting like a lot of the really bad
scandals are still done by that kind of
old-fashioned stuff BBC the guardian
um you know I had a very love-hate
relationship with the Guardians because
I think it's so annoying in some ways
but it's just
it is such a great British institution
it's done you know amazing work down the
years
um I just think it's wrong about
everything
I mean the guardian's always in finance
trouble if the Garden close I find I
think that's a really sad thing
um
but yeah I mean I mean this the same
same thing in the BBC I mean I think the
BBC can't basically
it can't never stop its biases but at
least it kind of understands them and it
does believe in a sort of an idea that
should be impartial I mean compared to
CNN which is just junk which is so which
is so bad it's like caricature
um I'm kind of glad that we do have a
sort of a state institution that at
least tries to
tries to be fair at least it has some
sort of idea I mean I I don't think that
will last because that if you look at
the BBC website which is written by the
kids it's just like this is crap I mean
this is this is what it's going to be
like for everywhere in the BBC in 20
years time it's again it's a generation
of shift which makes it so interesting
you say that because that was one of the
things that I you know having done quite
a bit of TV now just one of the things
that I never knew before I started being
on these programs and whatever
television is basically made by 20 year
olds yeah yeah I I never realized that
yeah almost all of the people you
encounter up up to the level of like
executive producer they're all in their
early 20s yeah so I just think it's kind
of inevitable that therefore that if all
the researchers and all the people that
are making most of the decisions which
is they are making most of the decisions
they're The Gatekeepers and there's the
that's the real power a lot of that then
um which is tangentially and stuff like
you know uh islands is a minute well I
mean on this look at sky sky was you
know quite
it wasn't right wing but it was kind of
like an ITV you know it felt like sort
of middle England and now sky is very
very more great it's much more like CNN
and that's a generational thing people
would tell me that you know the young
ones come and say oh you know in the
morning meetings then we must cover this
sort of classic Progressive issue and
then you raise sort of
a more you know delicate right-wing
issue
um maybe something's going on in
Rotherham or something and there's oh no
no I don't think that's appropriate for
and you know those decisions made by The
Gatekeepers
um
you know that's yeah the generational
thing is what worries me you know with
that Harper's letter on that
it wasn't about the trans thing wasn't
it I think everything's about the trans
thing these days and all these you know
I really admire these old style sensuous
liberals they believe and you know they
believe in freedom of speech they
believe in you know this kind of I think
slightly naive idea that if you all talk
about stuff you'll come to a reasonable
you know idea and they believe also that
their opponents aren't evil which is
like the central liberal of idea but you
know look at that average age there's
all about people with Stephen pink and
Jake are rolling on these people you
know I think great the average age is
like 65. well the the average age of
people you know denouncing them who
wanted them or on the chopping block
they were like 28 so this is awful but
this is our future is going to be like
do you know he's an optimist man yeah he
is
imagine being stuck with me for like a
week
I did not envy your wife yeah yeah
so let's get a little bit conspiratorial
about this do you think that there is
look at this yes
yeah absolutely do you not think there
is an element of divide and conquer
about the trans issue about all of this
stuff that we talk about because we're
so focused on these particular issues
that we don't for instance see you know
pretty Patel bringing in you know bills
you know that are going to limit the
rights of journalists limits of people's
ability to protest so it's a classic
diversionary distraction tactic would
you say no I don't think people think
that three probably I mean I don't think
I don't believe in consistency is I
don't think people are capable
functional like government can barely
function imagine the British government
actually organizing conspiracy they're
completely screw up yeah
just think these things happen
independent I mean yeah it definitely
suits certain interests that people
aren't focused on things you know like
Freedom you know bills involving
limiting people's freedoms processed or
I mean the big one is you know 10 15
years ago is all about you know the
Occupy wasn't it right so is that
economic issues right yeah I mean I
think it definitely suits big
corporations to go look at gay rights
trans rights look how nice which is why
they get money to be a layer man yeah I
mean the amount of money they give to
BLM you know
without wanting to lie by anyone I mean
a lot of people have all these movements
I've done quite well I mean you might
you know be a genuine believer
in that base you know if I was able to
get a million dollars
for my beliefs I would definitely leave
them more
and it's you know so like all these
companies I I get my Twitter I get all
these sponsored things from
yeah all these like massive big Banks um
telling me about you know
we must talk about diversity today we
really believe in diversity this is
great equality
and these are like the richest like most
Sinister banks in the world I mean these
like this is the man right they launder
drug money I mean and then they talk
about diversity I mean that it's
I started to think on you know the
hypocrisy about capital and after a
while I just I got so many examples I
just thought I thought maybe I'll write
a book about this but just after all I
just there are so many it just seems
that no one cares it's just it's like so
absurd it's like it's just a humorous
thing now you know it's like
sorry gay pride was sponsored by BAE
Systems they're like literally selling
and all these companies
um you know promoting and like if you
pay whatever one percent your
corporations to pay off some person to
say your pro-diversity that's like
nothing like a match compared to a
government saying no we're gonna we're
gonna massively punish you with taxes
which is what like the Orthodox left
would like
um I mean my I've become as I get older
I'm like more I suppose anti-business
just because but I think it must be just
like the culture must be the driver
because I think you you people are
horrible like you're so cynical and
manipulative I'd much rather they were
more like we are more economically
left-wing than social I mean I think
that
some old-fashioned that poverty actually
does matter it's like a real issue in
the same way that people's sexual
identity is like much higher on the
Pyramid of needs right you need food
first before you can start thinking
about your like higher spiritual needs
um yeah I mean that definitely I don't
think it's seriously but it definitely
it sort of incentivizes people to make
that yeah um I mean I worked very
briefly in a strange career path like
working for a financial company just
writing stuff I mean it's weird I mean
that unbelievably intelligent people
like
and it makes me realize journalists are
quite thick I was easily the stupidest
person like by far and then you know
everyone there was like
Pro remain for example but that's
definitely in their interests but then
you know they would be quite liberal
people probably like more old-fashioned
liberal they're not like radicals but
they would accept but it's easy for
easy for them to accept like Progressive
rules they could get they could they
could live with it
um because it's not threatening their
financial interests of course I mean
liberalism does dry you know economic
and social liberalism do go together
there is a reason why Britain is one of
the most liberal countries in the world
is the city of London is the prime
driver I mean Thatcher
was the creator of the sort of you know
the younger generation liberals
um liberals because I think inevitably
kind of becomes more and more extreme
until you know it's no longer liberalism
anymore
um
[Music]
sorry about that but but it's a good
points
family dinners must be must be fun at
the West oh yeah I mean my kids are
going to grow up I'm just I've kind of
kept off my Real views to them a little
bit I don't wanna I want them to sort of
be to be liberal as their kids I want
them to be you know enjoy your life
go to all these demos get get stuck in
it'll be fun you know and then when
you're a bit older you can you know
realize here's the red pill here's the
black pill
yeah exactly just enjoy yourself you
know but um
no Yankee but that's a big worry I I
don't know I I can't speak for everybody
but it's certainly a big worry for me is
like bringing children into this world
if if you're describing it accurately
and then what are you bringing them in
the world to
well I mean I don't know I hear that a
lot and it's not more about the the
environmental thing is normally that I
mean it's good
yeah I mean quite quite pessimistic
about the future of England really I
mean not what depend what happens in
America basically we're basically
dependent on them we're basically
dependent America taking the right
cultural choices now and not becoming
more divided and more extreme and sort
of more
I don't know my basic like fundamental
problems liberalism is that liberalism
and kind of both sense of the world is
that it just makes people unhappy
ultimately you just end up lots of
really
um kind of lonely disappointed people uh
who make really bad choices in their
lives whilst your needs kind of you know
basic not instruction but you need
you need kind of basic Pathways this is
what you're going to do unless you're
really
um unless you really feel otherwise you
know this is the normal thing that most
people do in life
uh but you know the New Order will just
encourage people to make terrible
terrible Life Choices I mean the classic
one is to come back to this you know why
don't you go and mutilate yourself so
you can't have children later which is
you know loads and loads of girls are
getting his message from Tick Tock do
just like let out all your most most
like anti-social disagreeable
personality traits and just you know
I mean The Tick Tock thing is what
really that's the really depressing
thing as a parent that is like the
pathway to such terrible ideas it's
um it's just basically a complete moral
Anarchy in there it's really it's
actually quite disturbing so let's get
into that so what's going on on Tick
Tock God I feel like yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's really
okay let's just one of the things you
can't say that you probably get in
trouble for is like girls tend to be
like a bit more conformist than boys I
mean and that's one thing Jordan
Peterson says in Knights says well you
can't say that it's like it's blandly
obvious so teenage girls are
particularly susceptible to ideas it's a
spread of ideas like like memes that can
spread the person circumcision
um
so you know it was anorexia on point
there is still anorexia self-harm and
stuff
um
like Tick Tock is just a complete world
of that you know um all these terrible
ideas are spread and you know one of the
problems you know we have generally
Society is that no one wants to be the
adult no one's to say no you can't do
that I'm telling you no it's not
happening everyone wants to be your
friend and that kind of extend the
children oh you must make the right
choice and
uh live
um that's really not a good idea for
children I mean I say as as a teenager I
made terrible choices I had no common
sense no real wisdom I'm not
particularly wise now but
um you know you need people to have
these kind of guides guides you like
this is the kind of this is what you
should do this is how you should behave
around people
um and Tick Tock is just all sorts of
rubbish coming I mean I think the
Chinese do actually censor it which is
or at least they sort of fix it's a pro
Chinese or what they want people to
um do well the Western one is just
Anarchy so it's just complete craze I
mean I think that is also what the
Chinese lesson will
to us in the future with their sort of
society we we have it ordered so you do
certain things I think that will appear
attractive to some people who have
enough of sort of the Anarchy
of what the Western model
um
with acid they have a side issue yeah
Tick Tock is just bad it's really really
five kids are not getting a smartphone
until they're about 30. correct yeah
well actually that is I mean that's an
example where that you know I think
there's just be it should be banned
2016s if all the other kids have to you
know smartphones it's very hard to say
to your child
you know you're going to be the owner
you're going to be the weird kid who
wasn't allowed ITV as a kid you know he
wasn't allowed to watch Green chill or
you know there's you're gonna be that
social outcast it's very hard as kids
are conformist that they said no my kids
are going to be social out because no
matter what happens
listen man it's been an hour it's fine
boy there's one question I want to ask
at the end right just this one you know
so you're saying the society is going to
hell in a Handcock but the thing that
I've really enjoyed about this so it's
it's presented in the sort of uh playful
English unattached one that might be
ironic I don't know nobody knows and
it's quite enjoyable and it's a bit
light-hearted but we are all about to
die yeah but here's the thing isn't that
the classic conservative position
conservatives have always gone Society
is about to crumble everything will be
right eventually
it's like my granny always thought she
was dying she's proof correct eventually
yeah after 50 60 years there we go do
you have any evidence that there's
you're more accurate you're closer to
like the there was a point when your
granny's saying she was about to die was
actually starting to get pretty yeah
yeah yeah yeah do you have any evidence
to suggest that your diagnosis for
society is actually a little bit more
accurate than I don't know than it would
have been 20 years ago
uh
if you went I mean I don't know we were
talking about in the office if you went
back to 2001 and you explained our
worlds to them
it would be pretty weird to explain the
whole thing yeah I mean we're just going
to tell everyone this is a war in Syria
which Al Qaeda were like one of the
moderate groups you know the the main
issue is about the rights for people
like me to go to women's toilets
um that's like The Cutting Edge of like
social justice
um
and by the way the government's just
locked you in your house for 15 months
oh yeah it's been actually mention
lockdowns that's interesting um see I've
forgotten about Kobe already it's just
it's all over
um
uh
yeah I don't know I mean
I don't want to say with doomed I think
things will just like continue as normal
weren't they for a while
I mean I can't predict more than 20
years I think we'll just slowly charge
on anything we're gonna have like
apocalypse here are we I don't know
maybe climate change would actually do
that
great uh so guys anyway tune in next
week for the end of the world uh the
interview and listen it's been absolute
pleasure uh I really enjoyed reading a
small man on the wrong side of History
thank you
um and as always we've got before we do
our questions for our local supporters
um uh we've got one more question for
you which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be I kind of actually mentioned
it it's the kind of tick tock and the
influence it's having on
um teenagers my most pessimistic thing
about Western Society is that the
victims of ideologies do tend to be
young girls
that's and and I think that's definitely
the case uh the uncertainty now about
like the sexual Revolution the biggest
victims of that are basically teenage
girls who are
you know all the studies show that they
are just more and more miserable and you
know sort of confused about everything
um
and you know if you spend any time
online that's clearly true of you know
you know even after they're 18 you know
in their 20s so many of them seem to be
like much unhappier than they used to be
and I you know I think that's sort of
the end of liberalism really that's the
sort of end product that's why people
have this kind of need for certainty
they need a new sort of order telling
them what to do so that sounds very
logistic doesn't it
um but I think yeah that would be like a
progressive you know that's you know
that's why the sort of people will turn
I think there is definitely things
people will turn about against like sex
positivity in the future there will be
some
I mean I think you would talk about
um will there be a reaction there'll be
small list of reactions in certain areas
I think
yeah there won't be a big Christian
religious revival but there will be
certain areas where there's a lot of
like kickback
um while in other areas you know things
will go on I think
Ed thank you so much for coming on the
show it's been a pleasure if people want
to find you where's the best place to do
that uh online yeah it's not your house
yeah yeah I guess on Twitter just Ed
West or unheard obviously just go to
unheard you find me it's a picture of me
somewhere and where can they get the
book
I guess Jeff Bezos is probably a thing
there we go we've all sold out uh Ed
thank you so much for coming on and
thank you for watching at home and
listening we will see you very soon with
another brilliant interview like this
one or our show all of them guys at 7pm
UK time which is 2PM Eastern take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the Bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals Community using the
link below